nous faisons avec vous de ce front sud
il ya évidemment des enjeux stratégiques
marina où est on en est exactement
on peut dire que l'armée russe tâtonnent
sur ce front sud évidemment vous le
disiez à l'instant la direction cod ça
la ville clé de ce sud de l'ukraine
l'armée russe tâtonne ou et bien autour
du port de nicolay fo vient de voir ce
reportage mais ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est que voyez ce port de me
coller nef ils ont étendu par rapport à
hier leur zone les russes ici et ici
avec toujours cette stratégie fut qu'ils
sont ils butent un peu sur nikolaïev
avec cette stratégie de contournement de
cette ville pour arriver vers odessa et
aussi de pouvoir prendre aux des sapes
la mer donc ces deux nouvelles zones et
puis gression aussi à noter sur le front
sud de nouvelle avancée vers la ville de
sapowicz est toujours contrôlé 1 par les
ukrainiens sauf la centrale nucléaire
évidemment la russie qui a l'intention
de faire du blocage de sa peau reach et
son absolue priorité dans ce front sud
un mot peut-être de ces corridors
humanitaires dont on vous parle depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant beaucoup
d'initiatives ont échoué rares
initiatives avoir fonctionné c'est celle
de soumis hier cinq mille personnes
évacuées on en annonce pour d'autres
encore pour aujourd'hui ou qu'est ce que
ça donne là aussi alors effectivement on
annonce des nouveaux corridors
humanitaires à prendre avec beaucoup de
précaution évidemment voir si ça
fonctionne sur le terrain en tout cas ce
que dit l'armée russe s'est cessez le
feu entre 9h et 21h avec six nouveaux
corridors alors je voulais montrer ces
corridors ça partirait de marioupol vert
zappos reach est également ici des nerfs
godard la centrale dont je vous parlais
à l'instant vers la porte et on a
toujours ce corridor de soumis vers
l'autre sauva voilà ça se passe il y en
a il y en a six
des corridors pour évacuer dit-on les
civils à avoir si les rues souvent les
respecter sur le terrain parce que
beaucoup d'ukrainiens disent que ces
corridors sont en réalité des pièges
pour les civils effectivement vous
parliez de la ville de soumis c'est là
et c'est cette unique endroit où les
civils sont évacuées la ville de soumis
vers poltava ici j'étais environ
5000 alors s'il y a toujours des
intenses bombardements en même temps que
des corridors qui sont annoncées dans
toutes ces villes c'est pour ça que je
dis que ces informations ils sont
vraiment à prendre avec la plus grande
prudence